[Music]
foreign
things off uh how do you think about
audience building and and what does your
audience mean to you Sean
oh wow emotional question uh how do I
think about it I think about it like
um
I don't really think about it it's the
byproduct of what I do so the way the
way I approached it was after I sold my
company I said all right
I could do whatever I want now so like
hey time to face the tough question what
do I actually want to do what do I
actually care about in my life uh well
and those are big questions that kind of
scared me so then I I trimmed it down I
said all right well how do I just want
to spend my days what would be a normal
it won't be a great day that I could do
every day and um the thing that came to
me was like
the thing I enjoy doing the most is just
getting curious I'm generally very
curious about things
and if I have to like go do work and
then put those on the side and hopefully
get to them when I get to them that
seemed like uh that was not great but if
I could just make my work that I could
just be curious about these things
whether it's crypto or it's audience
building or some new Science Tech thing
or it's you know where the hell you know
do peanuts grow on trees or from the
ground I don't know let me go find out
right like whatever it is I was like I
want to be professionally curious
all right well that's cool the Curious
part's easy how do you be professionally
curious well one way was let me turn
that Curiosity into content so I'll take
these questions and I'm I want to you
know go look into and then I just gotta
package up my learnings at the end and
share them with others all right cool
that'll make it more fun for me and
it'll turn into something that actually
generates a bunch of income which will
let me just do this all the time that
was my thought process so audience
building and content was just a kind of
a necessary means to an end or a
byproduct of the main thing I wanted to
do which was just be professionally
curious be able to wake up and just dive
into the thing that's most on my mind
that day and have no other restrictions
beyond that
about that uh I was talking about you
yeah I mean I think that building an
audience is a lot like making money um
especially in the year 2022 which is
that you have to provide something that
doesn't exist and then people will
commoditize it with their attention or
you know if you're a business then
you're building you're trying to get
Revenue so with the way that I built my
show and the way that I consistently
think about building and getting more
audience is just to continue to fill
niches you started out filling one
particular Niche built niches and niches
and niches put an underlying philosophy
that girds that and then continue to try
and build more on top of that which just
results in overall Top Line figure that
continues to go up I actually don't
think it's really that complicated as a
concept it's just incredibly complicated
to execute uh which is why not a lot of
people do it and there's really you know
not that many people at the very very
top of the game and why you know in the
whole influencer Market all returns are
exponential both you know the top 0.01
of podcasts get just so many more
downloads and even the top one percent
of podcasts like what I figured when I
found out what was even in the top one
percent I was like wait like 20 000
downloads I mean how can you I was like
I don't even know you make a living
um for something like that and then you
know you compare that to what the top
ten are so I think that execution is
harder than every anything else in this
game probably exactly the same as
business I mean it sounds easy to fill a
niche uh but actually doing that doing a
consistent basis over years and years
through changing conditions you know
changing market conditions for business
changing information environment um for
somebody who's in the content game
that's where the scale uh all comes into
play like simple simple not easy right
it could be simple what the answer is
but not necessarily easy like um we did
this uh like getaway like this getaway
where we wouldn't play basketball with a
bunch of interesting people and one of
the people that came was Mr Beast the
number one YouTuber in the world so he
you know he knows a thing or two about
audience building and it's like if you
talk to him you're like hey you know
awesome what's the what's the same
figure what's the trick for getting huge
on YouTube and he's like he's like I
just want to make the best YouTube
videos possible make great videos all
right
okay yeah but like yeah how did you do
it how did you become number one he's
like I just tried to make great videos
every day I just wake up and I'm like
all right what's a great video how do I
make that and it's like
simple not easy in the sense that like
he he didn't over complicate okay well
what makes a great video something that
gets your attention something that holds
your attention something that you know
makes you feel something at the end you
know laughter or a feel-good moment or
outrage whatever it is you could choose
uh and you could break it down from
there and add a little more detail but
fundamentally you're not going to get
some answer that's like damn um
I never thought of that all right wow
they had this Insight that's just not it
wasn't available to me and and now that
I have this Insight oh I too can go
succeed it's like the best the people
were the best do the simple thing just
better than everybody else
totally is is make great content is that
really kind of the
the bottom line here if you were to say
like what separates that top one percent
that soccer was mentioning from the
other 99 is it as simple as just make
great content or yes
um okay well you went through YC right
although you guys were you in YC we did
yes yeah what's the YC motto right YC
the greatest startup accelerator in the
world bardnon has a greatest track
record created almost half a trillion
dollars of value of the companies that
went through it what's the secret make
something people want is their motto
just trying to hey startup don't get
distracted by fundraising and press and
all these other things that you could
try to growth hacks are you making
something people want
of course really uh you know tell me uh
how do you know what gives you that
feeling and then there's sort of like I
don't know I just sort of assumed I was
it sounds so simple that I just sort of
assumed I was already doing that same
thing with content or audience building
are you making content that people want
right that's the that's the thing
because I just make great content it's
make content that people want that's
what great content is when he talked
about picking niches and then figuring
out how to serve that Niche that's what
he's doing he's making content that
people want in that category and then
doing it better than than others and
doing it consistently so they build a
habit et cetera et cetera I completely
agree yeah I mean I get approached by a
lot of people hey will this light do it
for me well this camera my camera's not
your problem bro I'm like your content's
problem I'm like
everything falls off the mat you know I
recently spent sixty thousand dollars on
cameras and that's after three years of
doing this but needing 4K cameras was an
added benefit for my existing audience
not what I needed for a requisite to
start like sure there's the Baseline
level of production I think a pop filter
uh like a Yeti USB mic and a basic
webcam and that is not a high startup
cost and everybody's like what about my
thumbnails what about my listen
thumbnails matter headlines matter all
that other stuff matters Etc but what
Sean is talking about which is that all
Mr Beast does is he knows exactly how to
rank a retention thumbnail all of that
stack it all on top of each other
iterate it a million times and then come
up with the quote unquote Secret Sauce
he has the exact same YouTube dashboard
that I have that all of us have that
that you have access to he just figured
out how to read it better than anybody
else so I always say is the content good
that's my number one concern is it good
is it compelling and that as he said
except simple it's not easy they're not
a certain point it is strange like it is
really one of those like you know it
when you see it I can listen to
something and be like that's compelling
and I can listen to something just like
I don't know what it is man but this
needs work
um and it's tough to exactly explain
what that is
yeah we listened to a session on
product-led growth yesterday and it was
almost like everybody was kind of like
well what's what's the hack what's the
tactic what's the secret and our
speakers were very simply like well you
need an A plus product in order to have
any sort of product-led growth and I
feel like the the principal stands
stands true for any form of audience
growth as well
um now both of you have pretty distinct
uh personal Brands as well as uh like a
business brand that you're you're both
independently growing either on accident
or on purpose
um how do you think about uh the sort of
brand building as a as a company as an
entity versus personal brand building do
you have any heuristics or ways of
thinking about it Sagar
um you know the way that you kind of use
your own Twitter versus
um breaking points yeah that's
interesting um so from a business
obviously it has to be whenever and Sean
you you too you're like you're in a
partnership right so this is inherently
not something that you have total at 100
freedom on so so whenever I'm doing
something under the BP umbrella or you
know business or hiring it's not
necessarily just a reflection of me it's
a reflection of the ethos and the
principles that we decided that we were
going to grow on mutually agree on
together re you know within that
framework everything is being branded is
being used that's a reflection of us of
our philosophy Etc on my personal brand
uh to be honest I just have a lot less
capacity for uh care I like if I'm
interested in it I'm just going to
explore it I frankly I'm at a level
where I can do that if I want to and if
people have only I'm just like I
literally don't care
um you know either Instagram you know
how hard it is
fine tweets that I'm able to show uh
yeah I was like I was a little scared
whenever you were like I was like oh man
I was like we're gonna piss off half the
audience but I mean that's fine you know
I'm used to it in this line of work and
that's kind of what I'm what I'm getting
at which is that there the business has
an orientation which is a make money B
perpetuate itself for me personally I
mean obviously my personal brand I
probably thought about this very very
differently whenever I was younger and I
was like on the up and up but at this
level I actually just do whatever I want
to do and so that is the the only
dichotomy between the two
uh how do you think about it Sean
so what kind of answer would be
interesting to you here what's like the
like uh because I try to figure out
what's the question behind the question
so so the question is the surface
question is like what's the difference
between your your pod brand and your
personal brand but what is the question
behind that
the question behind that here let me
start with the problem so the problem is
that audience building as a brand is
hard it's hard to uh create Affinity
when it's it's not uh coming from a
human face
um and uh people often find at least in
in the folks that I've I've chatted with
um even pers honestly demand curves
Twitter has has been difficult to grow
um versus like you know personal like
individuals as like Julian for example
has a much easier time with his with his
growth than we do as a company account
so uh yeah the question behind the
question that's a great question uh Sean
um is uh you know how how uh to uh like
how how should startups and companies be
thinking about uh audience audience
building when they have
um uh yeah but they have got like the
personal brand in there no I understand
no I understand yeah uh the question
really is like what am I doing wrong
here with demand curve hey but but more
generally speaking like I don't know the
it's I haven't cracked this nut what's
the difference I've noticed personal
brands are easier to grow but I also I
do I want my company thing to grow blah
blah blah I think that here here's my
like very simple slash controversial
take on this which is I think if you're
a company you should be using individual
faces to grow you'll go you'll go faster
that way if you're an individual trying
to grow like a media property you should
put it under a brand umbrella mostly
because you can't ever sell you
um so like if you wanted this to be an
asset and not a job you need it to grow
its own brand like you need breaking
points or like in our case like I had a
personal newsletter and a personal
Twitter That Grew really fast I grew my
personal Twitter from like 10 or 20 000
followers to it's at 300 000 in like a
year basically a year and a half in a
year we got to 200 000 and then it just
trickled up
um
but like great what am I going to do
with that I'm I I don't really want to
be some like influencer and
um and great like you know I can't hand
this off to anybody it's my voice is my
name it's my face so it's a job now I
need to maintain this thing and it's
cool because like I just don't get like
I'm like sorry I just don't care so I'll
go six weeks without tweeting because
I'm not trying to maintain some schedule
this is not a business of mine but when
I created the milk Road it's
intentionally not called Sean's crypto
newsletter which actually would have
been easier at the start to get
subscribers for because people already
had bought into the Sean franchise so
going for oh Sean is going to talk about
crypto and do crypto analysis and crypto
opinions great I want to know about that
but instead I called it the milk road
because I thought one day I'd like to
not be the guy writing this thing one
day I'd like to not be the person maybe
even owning this thing I'd like to sell
this someday
um I want this to be an independent
asset and so for that again me as an
independent media content creator I
created a brand umbrella for those
reasons but let's say it was my my
startup I would be saying hey I'm Sean
the growth guy from bibo and I'm going
to talk about growth over here not the
bibo account doing it because it's going
to get less play uh because people would
rather follow people than uh than
companies and so you got to use you make
that trade-off when you're already a
company then use the fact that people
would rather follow people if you're an
individual
you take a little hit by putting it
under a brand umbrella but you get this
big benefit of it's not tied to your
name and face forever that way so it's a
strategic bet that's my it's my opinion
on this yeah
well no it's super helpful uh and it
kind of points to the problem that we
originally had a demand curve where so
much of our brand Equity was tied up in
Julian's brand Equity uh and so you know
being able to build that up under a new
brand has certainly been something that
uh uh you know we've done over the last
last couple years so that's super
helpful
um okay we uh yeah let's go ahead and uh
start the repeat that tweet segment uh
here let's uh we're gonna experiment
with screen sharing for the first time
um
see how this goes
and uh yeah both of y'all the idea here
is for both of you all to just react to
the Tweet what were you thinking when
you tweeted it out why do you think it
took off why did it work uh and yeah any
other context that you think would find
interesting
I wonder what percentage of these I'm
just gonna be like I have no idea what I
was thinking I'm gonna believe that
that's stupid these are bangers only so
hopefully uh hopefully you remember
um Sean uh you you did this hot take
about everybody being wrong about the
metaverse obviously it was a very Hot
Topic at the time when he did this
um what can you what can you tell us
about this
um well I'll tell you kind of like okay
I'll tell you my point in a second but
like I guess that's a little less
interesting even than just the uh
what made this work so this thing for
each I think uh I don't know the exact
stats I think it's like sort of like
somewhere between 10 and 20 million
people in the US but then it also was it
got shared like crazy on Instagram and I
shared in China like some big Chinese
like social media influencers were
posting it I guess so I got like
millions of views there Logan Paul was
talking about on his podcast Mark
Zuckerberg referenced this in a Lex
Freeman interview so it like went really
far and I was like why did this go so
far and I think it was because it
basically had three things
number one it was timely so this is
right when Facebook had rebranded to
meta people were talking about the
metaverse and I think everybody had this
like
it was sixth sense of this little sort
of like you know sneaking suspicion that
everybody's bullshitting about this
um but like nobody knew it was all smart
people like big names that were saying
how The Meta versus the future but
nobody was saying what the hell the
metaverse is or why it's the future and
so like I think everybody kind of
smelled but didn't know how to
call it
um so it was timely I was calling
which generally is like
something people are going to want to
click into and read and the last thing
was I think I backed it up I think I had
a good point that could get you to agree
with my my conspiracy theory if so to
speak was not so far-fetched and
basically all I was saying was like when
people hear the word metaverse they
think about this like virtual reality
like oh I'm living in some thing
I'm an avatar now and I said actually I
think it's more like this concept called
The Singularity which is an artificial
intelligence which is like this moment
in time this Tipping Point where
computers you know have reached a super
intelligence and they're so vastly
smarter than than humans and they they
are so smart they just program
themselves to become it's like runaway
intelligence they program themselves to
become smarter and so um I thought oh
the metaverse is kind of like that it's
basically this Tipping Point where um
well a lot of my friends are online now
I think I have this experience many you
guys do look at this like experience
we're having now a lot of my work is now
digital
um my social identity like my profiles
my followers are all digital
um you know my if I buy nfts cool so my
art is not digital more and more things
more more things that are important to
you are now like they live on the
internet and so at some point all of
your digital stuff matters to you more
and you spend more time in energy energy
and focus there than you do in your
physical that doesn't mean you'll never
go eat or walk or exercise or anything
like that that's not what it means but
it just means like sort of there's a
Tipping Point where before rewind 20
years
it didn't matter you know I had a
computer room in my house uh that was
like you know there was a computer room
and everything else was non-computer and
now like you know the computer's
attached to my body basically right so
it's like you've seen this transition
already it's just going to continue and
so hey don't think it's this crazy
virtual world it's just this Tipping
Point where at some point we've been
creeping towards it creeping towards it
at some point we're just going to value
our digital stuff more than we do our
physical in the sense that we're going
to spend more time and energy and effort
and money on on the internet than we do
offline
um that was the idea so that's that's my
explain this tweet
super helpful man
um it was surprising to me uh during
your podcast with Hudson Minaj that he
was he was genuinely triggered by this
tweet uh it affected him as like an
identity level uh yeah he called me he
was like hey can I call you I don't know
the guy by the way I didn't know him
before this he's like uh he had followed
me from one other tweet that went viral
about Clubhouse and he then he he called
me and he was like
bro I like I do stand-up comedy and real
little crowds with real people that
energy that is my home that is my craft
that is my favorite feeling in the world
and like God I don't want this like you
know metaphor's like you know
and you know talk me through it and I
was like I don't know what to tell you
man like I think it's going in that
direction I don't think you know I
remember
I remember people being like I I love
waking up getting the newspaper bringing
it in from my front lawn and the feel of
the newspaper right and like uh it's
true you probably did like that thing
but guess what you liked more was like
instant real-time news constantly
flooding into your brain turns out that
that was more addictive
um that like you know being able to get
news from all these different sources
rather than just your local provider
that turned out to be really important
uh being able to access it only go on
your phone turned out that wasn't really
important and so yeah you like the feel
of it but there's all these other
benefits that like ended up crushing
that
um so that was uh that's what happened
after this tweet you conceptualized it
well you talked about kind of the
benefit of accountability uh it's a
double-edged sword here where you know
uh get the upside and the risk uh
involved in that uh super interesting
Sagar uh yes like like I said
challenging to find tweets I can share
with everybody here uh but uh
thank you
uh yeah actually I think they're most
viral is two days ago
um I I just saw that yeah uh yeah talk
to us about why why did this this tweet
work
um
what is this speaking to and like why do
you think this resonated yeah uh I'm
actually it's interesting I kind of
pivoted to becoming the gas guy
politically uh this really is really
just purely a function of what I talked
about earlier which is that if you were
to ask me why I think my show is
successful I think because I cover
things in a way that most people feel
are not being covered by existing
sources of information that's very basic
like thesis statement that's why I think
it does well I've always noticed that
coverage of gas is skewed in a
particularly partisan way so one of the
things that I like to do is just
highlight Basics textualize them
think that every American has to put
into their car on average a couple of
times or at the very least like once a
week a couple of times a month so uh
what did I do there I said the average
American Nets x amount of money after
taxes at five dollars a gallon that
means they're spending approximately 10
of their take-home pay on gas or when
you include food and housing it gives
you a picture of how bad things are
that's not a political statement that's
just like a statement about where things
are that got shared that's what I was
saying I mean people screenshotted it it
was shared on Instagram both ways it's
like a lot of you know oil companies
need to stop profiteering here's why
Biden needs to start drilling I mean you
can put it any particular way you want I
mean in general my most viral content
actually Auto just speaks to uh more
putting out like facts and then
contextualizing them in a way where
people feel like they can be used to
something that is very meaningful to
their life I'll give you another example
one of my most viral posts recently has
been about mortgages and it really was
just a basic uh take about like hey 2021
you could buy X house price house for
this monthly payment mortgage's price
has now gone up so now you get less
house once again like you can read that
whichever way you want like you can be
like congratulations Jerome Powell you
can say screw you drone pal like you
could put it uh any particular way so I
think uh to piggyback on what Sean is
saying I think timeliness is everything
uh everything so timeliness is you know
timeliness is number one it has to be
timely uh number two it has to be the
most viral stuff I believe uh has to be
able to resonate with somebody and not
tell them how to think just give them
the ability to then form something and
then three uh I think it's also concise
which is why Twitter is very very
helpful
yeah that that's great by the way this
um it's like you handed them like a
hammer and you're like don't beat up
whoever you want to beat up
exactly and this can be moved on any
anybody you know just Bingo use it to
serve your agenda which is like kind of
the like I don't know cynical take on
content creation which is like you will
blow up faster if you sort of gas up an
audience around something that they
already have a bias or or belief system
of and you feed that this happens for
example it doesn't have to be political
with crypto this happens all the time
which is like oh just be anti the dollar
anti-fed anti-born buffet anti-whoever
and you just keep feeding information
that like Riles up this zealous crowd
that already believes and all they're
looking for is like they're not looking
for real information they're looking for
information that just fits their world
view only and I I don't mean that to
pick on them because pretty much
everybody does this and so you know
everybody's looking for information that
feeds their world juice so one useful
way of thinking about it is what
worldview do I like and respect and
maybe share what worldview do I
understand and then that's the world
view that I can serve by producing good
packaged nuggets because I know what
will hit with that audience and then I
I'm focused on that versus just uh
generically producing content and then
not really thinking about the world view
that it's going to go live in
our software is the worst have you heard
of HubSpot see most trms are a cobble
together mess but HubSpot is easy to
adopt and actually looks gorgeous I
think I love our new CRM our software is
the best HubSpot grow better oh by the
way what's the what's the tweet that
went viral two days ago
oh that was about Dr fauci we don't have
to get into that one
what are we here to do
I mean I'll go into it I don't care uh
sure uh well although that's a derail
your uh
um for those who are not familiar with
something called the lab leak Theory the
theory is is that coronavirus leaked
from a lab and so the uh underlying
facts and circumstances around this are
pretty interesting the tweet that I did
was again you know actually speaks
directly to what you just talked about
Sean which is that if you're familiar
with the characters who are involved
there's one particular guy who served as
the cutout
um as so-called cutout of funding from
the NIH to the Wuhan Institute of
virology his name was Dr Peter dazak
he's been intimately involved kind of in
the cover-up of any facts or evidence
around the lab League Theory this I was
all old news at this point basically two
years ago that we've known all this
information well you know Dr fauci on
his weighing days uh as the head of
niaid actually just granted a 600 000
Grant to the same individual for the
same type of research which possibly led
to the The Escape of coronavirus from
the Wuhan lab that was it there you go
uh it's right in front of you
I said vouching his winning days
as you said I'm like here's information
why do I think it went viral I mean
that's not difficult because nobody else
was reporting it and millions and
millions and millions of people are
interested that's literally just a
screenshot from a government website by
the way yeah
um you said something like you know I
know a lot of people care about uh you
said like I know the gas issues
something a lot of people about that
they don't feel as being adequately
covered how do you know that uh you're
reading YouTube comments to get this
information you're talking to people
where how are you figuring out both what
my Niche is interested in and then where
they where there's a lack of service on
that topic is it because you're not
seeing it and so you're like oh I am a
customer that's how I know or you have
some feedback loop how do you do it at
this point is Art and a science so I
have a general intuition of like hmm
this is not being covered also the
reason why I got into gasp was because I
could see that my segments on inflation
were going astronaut like dramatically
High really what it is is I did a
monologue months and months and months
ago uh just it was very basic I was like
hey we are going to have an energy price
crisis this was actually before the
entire Russian invasion of Ukraine
because we were still having problems in
our gas supply and I was really obsessed
like why these specific market
conditions and it just went Mega viral
and I got all these emails from these
people being like hey man like thank you
so much like nobody talks about artists
like heating oil in Vermont and like
public contracts look like uh for these
things and you know for me and my family
I only make fifty thousand dollars a
year so when I have to lock in at X
price like it really really hurts and I
was like well that's interesting and so
then again you know you throw a couple
test segments and you're like do some
segments on it each one either
consistently performs or does more so
than normal I'm like okay well clearly
people care a lot about this and so what
I do then is like kind of use my Insider
ability as a guy who worked in the
Washington press Corps more to like
cover it in a professional manner and I
think that was the way that I could
discover but I also have a general sense
of you know I work in this media I work
working media I live in DC I know what
the people in power are talking about
and obsessed with and my general
orientation had to bet against whatever
that is and cover anything else and in
general
that serves me very well so there you go
that's cool I like that
one thing that Sagar shared maybe when I
when we get into more tactics later he
can cover this but one of the things
that worked for him early on was uh I
think you had said like
um just posting transcripts of like what
different people would say so if Trump
would say something all you would do is
just snip the transcript and just sweep
that out and let people have whatever
cake they wanted on it
yeah I mean I can share that so my first
50 000 followers uh I was I was really
obsessed with Twitter like obsessed uh
which is not a good thing uh I should
say when I was younger and I was like I
want to get more Twitter I remember
Michael I would say I want 50 000
followers I I had like four thousand uh
at the time I had a job I was a White
House correspondent I'm like okay well
how can I take advantage of this so all
I did was I just got really proficient
at using live transcription Services
which literally watched cable television
and then spit out rough transcripts copy
and pasting it taking out the cast
editing it for clarity and just trying
to be one of the first people to be like
Trump said X or the Secretary of State
said why and as you said Adel you're
just pumping information uh out into the
world this is why also you know I think
I probably have a timely bias because I
work in the news business like for us
Timeless is everything if you're two
hours late like you might as well be
dead you know you're a zombie and so for
for us like micro seconds especially in
the you know in the so-called like
information distribution game you're
competing against the Associated Press
against Warriors and uh you know like
major multi-million dollar professional
organizations it really just turned out
to be getting pretty good at tweeting
out transcripts so I think my first 50
000 followers all just came from people
who were following me in order to find
out like what was going on that day in
politics and since that was literally my
job I was both doing my job well and I
was building an audience
there's a lot of yeah there's a lot of
ways that people in this audience can
apply that I mean you're all in your own
Niche you all have uh the influencers
and the leaders in their in those niches
going out and doing uh appearances um
there's ways of adapting this strategy
not just in the news and time in this
context but even in the uh in Tech
um
timeliness uh oh yeah yeah exemplifies
it so I created uh or so there was this
big news event that happened in crypto
where this token called Luna crashed and
it had been one of the High Flyers and
then it goes to zero kind of like
overnight and I had a position in Luna
so I ended up losing was like a million
dollars in that crash and um I also had
kind of like an interesting take because
you need to have a take on uh you know
everybody knows what happened what they
want to know is you know either why it
happened or what it means and um so I
had a good take and I decided okay the
way I'm gonna do the and two things
happen hey I was a little bit busy that
week I was like on vacation stuff like
that came back back all right a couple
days go by and then I was like okay what
do I do either I'm just going to post
this as like you know
um you know a couple tweets a thread or
what if I made like a video on this and
so I go on YouTube I end up creating
this like almost like a like the John
Oliver show what's Last Week Tonight I
go and I create this like I'm like I do
this rant I I rant about Luna I rant
about why why it got big and then why
crushed I got devastated and it was had
jokes spliced in I hired this editor the
editor is amazing we're working on this
we're iterating on it we're making great
content
and we put it out
now two and a half weeks have gone by as
we put it out you can see this if you go
to YouTube Luna Sean or something like
that and the video has like I don't know
17 000 views or so uh 20 000 views maybe
at this point uh but it never went viral
and like so you know I consider that
sort of like a flop uh of a piece of
content especially one that I tried
really hard on and the funny thing is
like I kind of knew this that like like
the smarter thing would have been if I
literally had opened up my phone typed
out a thing in the notes app
screenshotted it and just posted it
immediately when it happened it would
have been less great because it was not
the jokes weren't as good the there was
no video production there was no nothing
but it would have been on time and on
time matters way more than great and
when it comes to this type of
reactionary what does everybody care
about right now because a lot of time
three weeks have gone by just nobody
cared about it anymore the world had
moved on there's two other crises to
worry about and so uh that was a lot an
expensive of time-wise lesson of of uh
how much effort I put into something
that did not go viral compared to
that did go viral because I did it you
know good enough at the right time is
better than great at the wrong time
totally agree
good enough at the right time is better
than great at the wrong time that is the
uh the quote uh and uh heck of a uh some
art here that you got going on Sean I
love it
um okay cool let's rapid fire through
one more each
um let's see so Sean we have your
Clubhouse one but I feel like it's
pretty close to the metaverse one as to
why that worked
um do you want to talk about uh this
Elon one or do you want to talk about uh
this learning one
uh yeah I'll do both real quick the Elon
one is actually like soccer was saying I
uh I I one of the threads that went
viral was not no original Insight uh
Elon was on clubhouse Elon like popped
onto Clubhouse when Clubhouse was hot
and you know just a guest appears by
Elon Musk is not something you get very
often and also Clubhouse was like
overloaded it was like invite only and
it was overloaded so I just go for those
who are locked out of the Evon thing
um here's what he's saying and I just
live typed and transcribed everything
interesting he was saying in a thread in
real time and I was the only guy doing
it and like you know on one hand I felt
a little silly I was like oh man I've
become like a professional Note Taker on
a Beta app of Clubhouse like
geez what does my career come to and
then also I was like oh wow that's just
like 7 000 likes already okay nevermind
shut up like go and so uh you know I
just like just did it but it was like it
it talks about that same thing which is
like some people think they need to have
this like really great Insight or
amazing you know perspective or whatever
and sometimes you're just providing a
service better than others you're just
clipping good content and you're posting
it and you're doing that consistently
and people will follow you for that you
can build a huge audience as simply a
curator or remixer of content you don't
even need to be an original content
creator I would say in most cases you do
not need to be
um so that's kind of what this one was
which was I just pulled this was
separately I just pulled out
um you know this this great quote um you
know by Elon and you know this is
another one where it fits people's world
view my my audience is mostly
entrepreneurs entrepreneurs love to have
this chip on the shoulder this Badge of
Pride about like how hard it is to be an
entrepreneur which I find pretty stupid
in general but I can play to it and so I
play into it here which is like Elon was
like you know if you need words of
encouragement for doing a startup don't
do a startup oh yeah like you know
that's right we are the special breed
and like we don't need this you know
motivational you know speeches whatever
so I knew that this would play and so
you know just threw out there and and
sure enough it hits
um the other one that you shared was
um oh yeah this was meant to trigger
people uh so everybody thinks that
everybody thinks that things like
education and Healthcare are like highly
nuanced topics and I find also that
really funny and stupid like um uh I I
think that Nuance is something that
smart people love to hide behind because
it's so easy to just say oh well you
know it depends and like you know it's
it's not so simple it's not so easy and
it's not so cut and dry it's not so
black and white it's not so binary they
love to like do this this nuanced thing
and so I knew I could trigger everybody
if I just said here I could fix
education
um in like a tweet and it's like oh
classic Tech bro thinks you could fix
education in a stupid tweet and so you
know I know how to like you know just
bait the animals uh with like here you
go right and it's something I do believe
which is that most people when they want
to learn something they start by trying
to learn it like go read about it they
watch about it they they go attend
seminars and workshops or take courses
about it and they'd be better off just
going and try trying to do the damn
thing and then when they get stuck they
should go look up how to get unstuck
like I do believe that that's true but
if I had just said that it would have
gotten a tenth of the likes by by adding
there I fixed education I was able to
trigger a bunch of people and so um you
know that was yeah these are the Jedi
Mind Tricks of the of the great creators
I mean I really hear that you relate to
Twitter as a game like it's not like uh
thing where you have to tell like what
you believed exactly the way you believe
it
um you're you're there's a bit of a game
that you're playing is that how you
would relate to it yeah don't take it
too seriously like
um I don't think anything too seriously
but definitely not going to be Twitter
of the things I think I barely take
parenting and like you know things like
that seriously I try to be playful and
silly and lighthearted with those too so
I'm definitely not going to take Twitter
too seriously and the other thing is I
uh I'm lucky that Twitter is not where I
like I'm not uh Twitter's not my my real
job you know like I've basically been
successful outside of content creation
so I had the security that I can just
kind of f around with content creation
and do what I think is interesting
because I'm not doing this in order to
become successful so I don't have to so
I didn't have this mental block of like
I need to play things a certain way
soccer was talking about this too like
once you get to a certain size here
whether you did it outside of content or
even through content you can start are
playing much looser because at the end
of the day your life's short just do
whatever you want to do say what you
want to say it's a lot more rewarding
and fun and interesting that way and so
uh you could do that you know you could
buy yourself that right
um but most people sort of have this
mental block where they're like afraid
and they take everything so seriously
and then it becomes an unpleasant
experience for them I think well I think
a lot of people don't don't enjoy social
media
um because they don't treat it like a
game you enjoy games you don't enjoy
things that are Ultra serious and so
um you know I think that's where most
people get it wrong
about that yeah uh having that that
block of like oh I need to get it right
I think is the kind of internal
conversation that that keeps people from
even even taking that action in the
first place soccer
um let's see we have this on student
debt or this on CNN plus which one would
you like to chat about uh
oh that I like that like that one that's
a good one uh narratively that I always
enjoy that so uh that one was yeah so
just for those uh oh man watching the
failure of CNN plus and lapsingo Obama
Spike are related so why is this tweet
successful you take two Viral Events
that are being discussed you pair them
together and then you put a thesis
statement on why exactly it supports a
broader meta-narrative shitty
establishment content previously force
fed to us in cable Monopoly era simply
cannot compete in the free market
streaming the revolution has just begun
so revolution's just begun Punchy feeds
the thesis you know most of the people
who follow me and I in general anybody
below the age like 50 doesn't like cable
Monopoly and cable news so obviously
huge uh Market there you know biology
actually said biology screen of action
one says something to me is always spent
on charts it's just you got to find the
right chart to bet on and so I always
say that uh the right chart for me is
trust in the mainstream media which is
13 that means my market size is 87 of
the United States so I only have even
more to grow and if you put a globe on
that team you're like man so I feel
sorry for CNN serving this Niche 13 of
the audience poor guy if they need some
help I got you it's about flipping
things
it's like no no it's like you're the one
who's only serving they need so putting
these two things together the Obama
Spotify contract CNN like two Legacy
established political uh both Brands
kind of in their own right everybody
knows but yet not a lot of people are
consuming and then putting them together
and saying and trying to describe a
market condition that is arising that
can tell us about why these two things
have failed that goes against the way
that people who actually work in
professional media explanation uh are
able to tell you I mean to date I have
not seen a a
dispassionate view maybe out of one or
two people I can count on one hand Sarah
Fisher over at axios I think she's
awesome uh there's like uh Dylan Byers
over at Puck news I think he's a
straight shooter too those two are
pretty much the only ones I've seen with
like an actual rundown of like why these
things don't work uh compared to the
amount of money that are being invested
in them the Obama Spotify contract it's
the same one it's like you know they
paid the former president of the United
States millions of dollars and it just
didn't do that well when he was paired
one of the biggest rock stars on Earth
that's that's kind of insane I mean you
have somebody who hundreds of millions
of people uh knew that no he's billions
of people probably know his name uh you
have somebody who received like 10
hundreds of millions of votes
collectively over two elections and yet
he can't even crack the top ten on
podcasts like how does that how does the
former MMA cage fighter beat this person
like how is that possible and so that's
a very interesting story now nobody
wants to tell that story because you
know when you work in the quote-unquote
powers of B you're gonna offend the
wrong people and so it again that's just
a niche that opens up for me to come in
and to fill that so I think that's why
that it took off it was it's not not
even a difficult one really to explain
cool no that's that's I like that take
two Viral Events Stitch it together with
a thesis statement uh and then cater it
to that uh 87 of the audience uh who
doesn't trust in the mainstream media
very clever
um cool well let's go through uh some
rapid fire questions tactical questions
uh and some uh questions from the
audience uh over the next five to seven
minutes uh and then we'll call it a day
um soccer talk to us you know you
mentioned the strategy that you did
early on
um
kind of just taking scripts of what
other more influential people are saying
um like what were really the inflection
points or uh tactics that took you from
from that first zero to 100K uh let's
say Twitter okay so zero to Twitter is
actually not that hard which is that
most of the people follow only a few
amount of accounts so get those few
amount of accounts in order to follow
you and get them to retweet you and
that's basically the secret to growth I
don't think it's like a complicated so
what does that mean it's like well find
the that Niche the 0.01 what do they
need in their feed that they're not
getting provide that service for me I
was the first guy in order to tweet the
transcript which means that they were
all following me which means they're all
retweeting me and exposing me to their
millions of followers which means to
some people would then follow me so for
me it was I would say around 10K is a
big is a big challenge uh for some
reason in people's minds it's like when
you cross ten thousand that is a point
where you're going to get exponentially
more new numbers of followers what I've
discovered across all my platforms the
more followers you have the easier it is
to get followers which is so frustrating
whenever you're starting out you're like
when you're oh man five thousand that at
that point if I had five thousand
followers on Instagram which you know
once upon a time was the case if I got
50 I was like oh my God I lose 50 a day
uh to now actually more probably more
like 100 and yet I'll net out you know
at a thousand a week or something like
that and it's simply because of like the
churn the burn the way that your
algorithmic treatment um is offered so I
think 10 is a big inflection point I
think 50 is an even bigger inflection
point that's where things really begin
to go vertical and you know this is
probably the same startups which is just
getting that you know uh first initial
customers and then compounding that to a
sustainable-ish business is like the
really most difficult requires the most
amount of thought because at the end of
the day that's right that's where you're
filling the niche that's where you're
discovering the niche that's where
you're uh playing around that's that's
that's really the time too of the most
experimentation uh where you have really
really high stakes so I would say it's
there and then also on the other end
where you know after I reached 300K
actually after I reached 200k on Twitter
I was like I just don't care anymore I
was like if it goes up it goes up I
could care less you know my business is
almost entirely dependent on YouTube and
I frankly I care more about Instagram
um than I do about Twitter I think I
have much higher quality engagement
um just from what I've seen my ability
to sell either my subscription tickets
uh any of those things are there so then
it just became a complete game after
that I just genuinely did whatever I
wanted so those are kind of the
interesting inflection points
well yeah I like the idea of uh finding
look there's a few accounts that
everybody follows like it's almost
account based marketing at that point
where it's getting and in touch and
making an impression with those nodes
those sort of super nodes in your in
your industry
um Sean do you have any uh anything to
add
uh that's smart I wish I had done that
um it didn't have that Insight but I
learned something great today
um yeah mine was sort of like uh this
actually it was the same but I did it in
a much slower stupider way which was the
first kind of 25 people mattered a lot
and so it's not the number it's who
those 25 are for me I built those
relationships in person so like um you
know Ryan Hoover had a popular Twitter
and I had known Ryan in person you know
for you know seven eight years at that
point and so once I started getting
active and started saying things he was
happy to kind of like share I never
asked him to he just he followed me
already he thought some things I said
was interesting and he would share it
with his audience and um and then that
happened with like 25 important people
in Tech that were already well known but
I had built in-person relationships with
them build in-person credibility with
them and so it's kind of the same idea
actually but just a very slow version of
what he just talked about and I didn't
think about it like creating content
that that serves them um that they would
want to share with their audience I just
thought like it just it just
accidentally happened so it's you know
sort of along the way
um
the main things that I would say is like
you know
uh figure out your you know the the
domain you're trying to build your
Authority in so you know get really
tight on that the tighter the better uh
but it's very tempting to be broad
um and I've made this mistake many times
I just like being like well it's that
but it's also these other things that I
like and there's also this and it's also
that and actually you'd be better off
just starting off uh starting up there
um then there's basically like some
tactical things like you know for
example uh there's this Theory called
The Red Pill Theory I guess uh I think
in politics just has a different
definition but I heard it when I talked
to the guy
um there's two guys who do weight but
why and so there's like Tim who's like
the writer the famous guy and then this
is his friend Andrew who
childhood friend who helps run his
businesses and Andrew I talked to Andrew
and Andrew was like yeah you need to
have your red pill which is like you
need to have the truth that you can say
that people that wasn't like um it's not
the thing everybody's saying but when
you hear it people like some said the
same with people will nod their head
vigorously right so what is the answer
other people call this your spiky point
of view it's like you know what is your
what's your thing right like you know
maybe your thing was like that inflation
is a way bigger problem the government
is playing this down boom that's your
red pill and you can you can base your
whole brand off that for a period of
time and then you have to eventually
swap out and create a second red pill
which is like you need to be giving
people and by the way red pill comes
from like the Matrix where it's like do
you want if you take the blue pill you
go back into the Matrix you just live
like a sheep again and you just don't
question anything or do you want the
truth and that's the thing you're trying
to give people the truth in a way that
they're not that they haven't been told
and then you can become known for that
and so I think that's important that's a
very useful tool I think some other
tools are speaking from the eye I I
found great success in this which is
a lot of people in um the more
successful that they get they'll just
keep saying you like a fortune cookie
like oh you you gotta do this you got to
do that you know when you feel this way
you got to try doing this and it's like
it's much more powerful when you're like
you know uh I was feeling this way or I
was going through this I had this
experience and it made me think this but
what I need to do differently is I need
to do this
um it's a much more I think in general
it's good for personal accountability to
speak from the eye but secondly I think
it plays really well into content
because it's different than what
everybody else is doing so same thing
personal stories
um and speaking from the eye I think
works but like the high level things is
you know you could be either a generous
expert sharing your knowledge and
expertise or you could be a curious
novice and a curious novice is somebody
who's just going through like you're
saying you're just typing out the
transcripts you're just finding
interesting clips and sharing it you're
remixing packaging curating and
presenting you know stuff as a
beginner's point of view rather than
saying I know everything
um so you got to know what areas are you
an expert in and what areas are you
going to be a curious novice and then
use both in your content
um and the last is just I don't know
don't quit and go viral like that that's
ultimately like if you want to win don't
quit and like find ways to go viral or
you won't grow so uh if you just you're
only gonna remember two things on the
strategies like don't quit go viral I
would say the the takeaway
I could talk to both y'all for another
hour this is uh awesome uh yeah just the
the the nuggets at the end non-stop I I
think we're gonna create an illustration
of this uh to capture a lot of those
things so stay tuned for that
um yeah thank you both so much for
spending your time with us today uh this
is a ton of fun
[Music]
foreign